good morning Hank it's Tuesday May 5th
happy-happy happy-happy happy-happy
birthday is your birthday
hooray hey tango DeMayo cinco de Hanko
pincode mio
you're 29 that makes me feel really old
Hank as you may have noticed lots of
nerdfighters are giving you lots of
wonderful presents all over the Internet
today I put links in the sidebar to some
of my favorites and now I'm gonna call
you and tell you about the present I got
you or em in the process of getting you
you know how there is this pizza
restaurant with like fun balls called
chucky cheese you know how before chucky
cheese there was a place called Showbiz
Pizza and Showbiz Pizza had an
animatronic animal based rock band
called the rock afire explosion okay my
present to you is that I found the very
rare original printing record of happy
birthday medley on one side and do you
love me on the other and also I'm in the
process of getting the actual rock afire
explosion to record your song book eight
that's your real present if all goes
according to plan
the raca fire explosion will be
recording Hank green music would you
have thought Hank when you were like
eight years old listening to the rock
fire explosion that one day you would
write a song that they would record
right right and then my 11 year old self
would have like held you down underneath
the fun ball so you couldn't breathe
yeah I would say that I'm sorry but hey
I'm not sorry and B I think having a
deep fear of fun balls is actually quite
healthy it in fact it's now believed
that swine flu started inside fun balls
the scientists are actually thinking
about renaming it fun ball flu
have a great day with with the Katherine
healthy wishes healthy wishes I said it
just now but I will say it again happy
birthday and I'll see you tomorrow